- There are all these
business books that say,
"Hey, be humble, be humble, be humble,"
but humility is not a natural state
for a kick-ass human being.
I was writing terms and
conditions for websites,
some of which turned out
to be adult websites,
but they paid cash.
And Travis Kalanick,
while being CEO of Uber,
was ranked number two in
the world at Wii Tennis.
(laughter)
Who here wants to compete
with a guy like that?
Some of you aren't
founders, and you should
admit that to yourselves.
- He's a former lawyer,
venture capital investor,
company advisor, and entrepreneur.
He's the proprietor of Lowercase Capital,
a venture capital fund
in the United States.
He invested in seed and
early stage companies like
Twitter, Uber, Instagram, and Kickstarter.
He's Chris Sacca, and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success.
Rule number five is my personal favorite.
I'd make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus
clips, and as always,
as Chris is talking, if he
says something that really
resonates with you, please
leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it, so other
people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(swoosh)
(upbeat music)
- Too many investors
invest in the things that
they just like and are
comfortable with and are within
their own little bubbles,
and yet, I think the
distinction we like to make is
invest in things we know we can
personally impact the outcome of, so
everyone can be talking
about the hot biotech field,
and it might be on the
verge of curing cancer,
but I cannot do anything
to advance the mission
of a biotech company, quite literally,
and so we pass, as cool as it may seem.
If I'm going to mooch, I might
as well mooch in the public
markets, right, and just throw darts
and ride the greens and
reds, so if I believe
that I can take something
that's already a good company
and just make it a little
more likely to be a success,
then that's a rigged game for me.
It almost feels unfair, right?
And I can just be that
much more confident that
the investors who give me their money,
I'm going to give them their money back
and a lot more after that.
I'm a big believer in the
liberal arts education.
I think it's overrated, or
it's underrated, I mean.
In that, the computer
science stuff is overrated.
It's great, technical skills are amazing,
but what has happened,
as I referred to earlier
is we've just, all the storytellers
are kind of gone, and the actual
understanding of our users is gone.
We've lost all that sensitivity,
and yet I feel like that
sensitivity comes first
from really knowing yourself, so
I encourage people to take classes,
not just in art and music,
but in death and dying
and philosophy and
theology, these things that
you'll never make money on directly,
but I think one of the
most important things
you can do is be interesting.
I only really want to
work with people who have
not only had those crappy
jobs I've talked about,
but are also interesting.
They have stories.
There's some meat to them.
There's some flesh.
There's something really compelling.
That's who you want to be with
if you're going to spend night
and day building something together.
That's who you want to travel with,
these people with these
perspectives and these stories,
and so, and interestingness
is not something
that I think you're born with.
I think it's achieved by
vulnerability, by adventure,
by all these things,
and so I really emphasize interestingness.
I think you can get it from
from studying, from reading, from putting
yourself in uncomfortable positions.
Maybe more Americans should
just hang out naked in saunas.
That could make them more interesting,
but traveling abroad, going to
Ethiopia and helping dig wells.
That kind of stuff I
think builds a much more
impressive character,
so Stewart Butterfield,
who runs Slack, obviously one of the most
successful investments in our
portfolio, an amazing company.
Stewart is a liberal arts major.
That do is fascinating.
Like hanging out with that guy and talking
about anything beyond Slack is amazing.
He's Canadian, and yet he's got
great insights into U.S. politics.
But you just follow his snaps on Snapchat.
The guy is, he eats well,
he's checking out art,
he knows music really well,
he's a really interesting guy,
so he becomes a magnet for talent.
You want to be around Stewart.
He enriches your soul, and
if you look at the team
of people he's recruited, super stars
like April Underwood, for instance.
He's really recruited an
incredibly deep bench of people
because they want to have
authentic and multi-dimensional
relationships with him, and I think
it comes through in the product too.
It's time for step three.
Step three is to go on offense.
Now what do I mean by going on offense?
Well, you guys all know sports.
This is the Big 10.
You can't avoid sports here.
You know what it means to be on offense.
Offense is calling plays,
managing the clock,
keeping the other team on
defense reacting to you.
Now take that term and apply
it to the rest of your life.
Let's take for example, e-mail.
Is your e-mail inbox offense?
Is that playing offense?
No, no, no, inbox stuff is
just defense the whole way.
Imagine if you took your to do list,
and you posted it on the
door of your dorm room
with a little pencil there
and invited the entire world
to come and add anything they
wanted to your to do list.
Well that's what your inbox is.
It's a publicly posted to do list
where it's up to everybody else
to impose their whim on you.
And even worse, what happens
is we get up and it's the very
first thing we check,
and so we get in there,
and we start doing stuff
for all these other people,
and yet, along the way,
we've forgotten what
we wanted to accomplish for ourselves.
We haven't done the things that we know
are important for us and for our goals.
And so that stops now.
It's time to close your e-mail
and write out your to do list.
I don't just mean your
to do list for work.
I mean the big to do list for your life.
What do you want to get done?
It's an awesome time in history
to be authoring our own
futures in real time.
I mean the internet makes it
possible to be just one degree
away from anyone in the world.
Any one of you right now can
send me a reply on Twitter
if you had your phones out,
and I'm that accessible.
Any one of you right now could
use the internet to become
an expert in any subject at all.
In 2007 back when I was at Google,
I went from not knowing
anything whatsoever
about the wireless industry
to leading a group that
led a 4.7 billion dollar
project that turned Verizon,
AT&T on their heads,
sent the FCC spinning,
and changed the landscape
of wireless forever,
paving the way for the apps
we all have on our phones today.
Never in history have their
been fewer barriers in the way.
No matter where we come
from, what our parents did
for a living, how much money we have,
we all can be unqualified successes.
So who do you want to talk to?
Where do you want to spend your time?
What do you want to learn?
You just spent four
years, maybe five or six,
but we'll just forget that,
four years for the most part,
taking the classes you
were required to take,
so now it's your turn to go on offense.
What are you curious about?
Where do you want to travel?
What adventures do you want to go on?
Which fears of yours
do you want to tackle?
You know offense also means
owning your personal brand.
Your voice should be the
first two or three responses
when I search for your name on Twitter.
I'm sorry on Google.
But how do I, how do you get there?
You Tweet, you post,
you blog, you comment,
you engage in discussions,
you own your own identity.
The tools are there to
have a public identity
and to go on the record, proudly so,
and stand for who you really are.
I mean think of it.
I hire a lot of people for a lot of jobs.
Imagine, why would I ever hire
somebody just on the basis
of a resume, when instead I
can search for them online
and get years and years worth
of insight into who they
really are and how they think
and how their ideas evolve
and how they react to the
changing world we're in.
Those tools exist for
you to create your own
authentic brand, completely
within your control.
And do it.
I mean sitting back and
watching television,
that's playing defense,
but going outside and being
with your friends, that's offense.
Provoke, inspire, don't just get involved,
but inspire others to be involved.
That's playing offense.
In the spring of 2000, I was way
over-leveraged into these two stocks.
In a matter of a few
days, I found myself going
from 12 million dollars to
the good of four million
dollars to the bad, so I was 25 years old,
I owed 4 million dollars.
I didn't have anything to show for it.
I didn't have a house or a
boat or a plane or anything
I could sell to pay it off.
I just owed, I owed it, and I came
from a middle class background.
Neither of my parents ever made more
than a hundred grand in a
year, and I was just stuck.
And I had to make some choices then
about whether I was going to quit, and
or you know or try to declare bankruptcy
or whether I'd try and fight it out.
And it happened
just as I was graduating
law school actually,
and so I said, "Well I'm going
to try and fight this out,
"and I'll take a sellout
job as a corporate lawyer
"out at Fenwick and West,
"and I'll try and grind this out."
And so during the day I
would do corporate law stuff
at a tech firm, and at
night, I would do pretty much
anything that somebody would pay me to do,
short of giving blood or massages.
- Did you use like Craigslist for this?
- I did go on Craigslist.
I was writing contracts and business plans
and renaming companies.
There's a thing called Elance out there.
There's now like oDesk and
Rent a coder and stuff,
but Elance was the first of those markets,
and I was the first lawyer on Elance,
and so I was writing terms and conditions
for websites, some of which turned out
to be adult websites, but they paid cash.
(laughter)
And so I even did a
voiceover for a book once.
Yeah, who knew, but I actually
screamed for a few hours
to make my voice raspy, that
was what they were looking
for in the character, so,
but I just did anything I
could to try and pay off
this debt, and it took me from then 'til
basically the Google IPO,
to selling another company
in the Google IPO before I
got back to zero of networth.
And I'll tell you, no matter how early
you are in your career, the
richest you will ever feel
is when you owe zero dollars to anybody.
That's the very first time in your life
when you've got choices.
You can, you could go
join the Peace Corps,
you could go travel the world,
you could do anything.
I actually celebrated by throwing
a BYOB party at my house.
Like I'm not going into the
red to treat all you guys, so.
(laughter)
But that was a real
pivotal moment in my life.
I'll tell you, I just
I never really considered
any other option.
I never considered moving
back with my parents
to Buffalo, New York.
I never considered declaring bankruptcy.
I just kind of always knew I
would fight my way out of it,
and I think that's something that,
for those of you who are founders,
I'd encourage, not everybody's a founder.
It's easy to kind of sign the paperwork,
but some of you just aren't founders,
and there's a time when you
have to admit that to yourself
that it's cool to have a startup,
but you may not be a founder.
You may not be the kind of unstable,
mentally askew person
with a slightly
manic-depressive side, who is
who knows in the face
of insurmountable odds
that you're going to win, and I don't mean
is convinced that you can sell people
and convince people of that.
I mean you know in your bones
that you're going to make it out,
and I think that's something
that was a little different
about me, was like, in that
whole as advisor was just
saying, "Look just go bk
and seven years from now,
"you can walk away from it."
I just knew I would
fight my way out of it.
And I didn't have to convince
myself or anybody else.
- I mean, you are
unforgivingly who you are.
Have you always been like that?
- [Chris] No.
- [Interviewer] What happened?
- Like when I was in college--
- [Interviewer] What were you
like, were you ever insecure?
- I still am insecure, like
there's probably people
snickering backstage right
now at that question like
(snickers)
I, when I was in college,
I didn't want to come out
as a progressive because I
would eliminate like half
of my future employers,
and in Washington, D.C.,
I was like, look I got
to look neutral here,
so I can get a job someday.
I found
progressively, and you know,
some of these lessons
were foisted upon me.
I mean, I mentioned earlier,
so not to repeat a story, but.
It's at Google, I'm working on this
team and this wireless stuff.
It was an incredible
amount of responsibility.
Larry had given me, Larry
Page had given me billions
of dollars to go take on
the wireless carriers,
and I was in over my head.
I didn't have a background in this stuff,
and I was learning fast,
and I was pretty good at it,
but one day a decision came
up, and I didn't know what
to do, and my work partner
wrote in the notes,
Chris doesn't know what to do about this,
and at Google, the notes are
published to the whole company,
so I see the notes get published,
and I'm like, "What'd you just do?
"You just ruined my career.
"Everyone's going to know
I'm smoke and mirrors."
And I thought it was over for me,
and then the next meeting,
some new engineers,
who didn't report to me, and
Larry Page, himself showed up
with ideas on what to do
to solve this problem,
and I was like, "Oh my god,
I just became more powerful.
"I now have influence.
"I have more bodies working for me,
"who don't even report to me."
And it was, I mean I wish I could say
it was an enlightened choice I'd made.
It was totally foist upon
me, and I was angry about it,
but it worked, and so along
the way, I realized that
the candor, the authenticity,
the vulnerability,
is what actually attracts
the other people to you.
It's, the insecurity
roots you in this place
of showing you're impervious,
that you've got all the answers,
but what that does is it
renders everyone around you
helpless, they're just like,
"I'm not valued here," right?
And so when you start to admit
I don't know what I'm doing.
I need some help.
Then people start attracting
to you and working with you.
I mean, I have a principle
that I guide my life by,
and I try to teach this to our
entrepreneurs, called bold humility.
There are all these
business books that say,
"Hey, be humble, be humble, be humble,"
but humility is not a natural state
for a kick-ass human being, right?
If you're here, you probably
kick a lot of ass at something.
You're probably the best at something.
You have ambition, you're a risk taker,
you have learned to hack,
you are a good talker,
you have through the gift of gab
wound your way into an amazing situation,
you hustle, hustle, hustle,
and I feel like it's
unnatural to apologize
for that, but where we get
into trouble is when we feel like we have
to extend that to the shit we don't know,
and we have to feel like
we've got it all covered,
and so I think I have had such a great.
I don't know if I would have
learned this authenticity
if I didn't have Twitter,
and the replies being like
"That means a lot to me, go for it,"
and that's why I kind of live
a lot of my life in public
because I feel I draw a lot of
strength and reassurance from
the public being like,
"Look that moment of
"failure meant a lot to me,
and I identify with it."
- You haven't done every investment right.
Tell me about the worse
misses that you've had or
sort of the biggest setbacks there.
- Every investment you get
into, you're getting in there
because you think you
have an airtight thesis
on why this thing is going to work out.
You're convicted, you're
passionate, you're putting not just
your money in, but all your
time and effort, your own brand
and your reputation is on the
line, and more often than not,
we're wrong, but even more
painful are some of these ones
where I didn't invest at all,
and they've gone on to
be the mega unicorns.
I think about
Airbnb.
When they told me the pitch
about renting out a room
in somebody else's house while
the owner was still there,
I literally looked those
guys in the eye and I said,
"You guys, this is so
dangerous, and somebody's going
"to get raped or murdered and the blood
"is going to be on your hands.
"I think this is just a really bad idea."
I think they're currently
appraising at a 20 billion dollar
evaluation now, so that means
my fund probably missed out
on hundreds of millions of
dollars as a result, right?
Well I only have two speeds
like asleep or going all out.
- All out.
- Life is way too short
to do anything else,
but I seek out argument.
You know, Travis Kalanick
is just one of the most
opinionated people in
the world, and the nature
of our friendship is beating the shit out
of each other, you know.
- I've heard that there's a Wii
Tennis Wii racing anecdote, you
want to extrapolate on that?
- [Chris] Maybe some of
you guys know this story,
but it was New Year's
Day, like 2010 maybe,
Travis was staying up at
our house in the mountains,
and my dad loves playing
Nintendo Wii Tennis.
He's pretty good at it actually.
And so he says, "Travis, Travis,
come on, let's play Tennis.
"Let's play," you know,
and Travis is bleary-eyed
'cause we've been up all
night for New Year's,
and he says, "Okay, Mr.
Sacca," and they start playing,
and my dad is like up
swinging and going for it,
and Travis is just sitting on the couch,
like eyes barely open, kind of doing this,
and he's beating my dad, who's
getting visibly frustrated.
He's sweating, and he's swinging hard,
and he's like, "What the hell?"
And then Travis does that
like Princess Bride thing,
where he's like, "I'm sorry, Mr. Sacca,
"but I'm not left-handed."
(woosh)
(laughter)
So he starts playing right handed,
and he's making movements this big.
Just that, and he's acing my dad.
My dad just like, "What the
hell is happening here?"
And Travis said, "Okay,
Mr. Sacca, I'm sorry,"
and he uses the remote to page over
to the global leader
board, and Travis Kalanick
while being CEO of Uber was ranked number
two in the world at Wii Tennis.
(laughter)
Who here wants to compete
with a guy like that?
He was also globally ranked.
He was like a top 10 Angry Birds player.
The guy's a maniac, right?
So, anyway, I seek out
people who are not normal.
I seek out weird people.
Like I won't invest in anyone
who's not really weird.
I think you need to have
some kind of imbalance
to do this well, and
that's what's exciting.
I mean I get most excited,
so I'm on this show back in
the United States, Shark Tank.
I know everyone has their
different version of it,
and people ask why I agreed to do it
because the deals there
probably aren't going to make
me any money or anything,
but the biggest draw
is if you watch that show back home,
you're like, "Mark Cuban,
you're full of shit," right?
And so I get to now go on
the show, and on behalf
of all of America, who
wants to bust his balls,
I get to do it from a few
chairs away, and he's wrong
most of the time, and so
that's like a sport for me.
- Well you make a good
point, it's old tech,
but there's a ton of
old tech in real estate
because it's so sleepy valley.
- I've already seen
the new tech out there.
- No, no that's not true.
- What do you mean it's not true?
- That's denigrating damn, Chris,
because the key isn't the software.
The software is the easiest part.
- No, no, no, like Mark, you're not
making any sense at all now.
- I'm making total sense.
- [Chris] No, no, no, you're not.
We're, no, no, we're.
- [Mark] How stupid are you?
- [Chris] Are you aware of that place?
- I know this is going over your head.
- No it's not.
- [Mark] Do you think people drive
down the street and look for houses?
- They see their dream home, they see
a for sale sign, they'd love to get in.
(overlapping conversation)
- What do they do?
- Mark, the device exists today.
It let's you in by
Bluetooth on your phone.
- Not in that circumstance.
- With one new line of
code, it can let in anyone.
- [Mark] So in your example,
drive by and I want in now.
Right now.
- [Chris] Yep.
- Right now, who do I call?
- So you ping in the, no look, look, look.
It exists in.
Hold on.
- Exactly.
- Shut up and listen.
Don't be mad at me that I understand
this better than you do.
Look you're saying, "He's got
some special way of getting.
- No! No! That's not--
- [Chris] And they're
already ahead of that.
They had a can't see that.
- You have to go through the agent to get,
in order to get, the agent's.
(overlapping conversation)
- This is how any agent gets
into a house with the other technology.
They walk up, boom, they're in the house.
- So what you're saying
is what the agents do,
you can enable for the consumer to do.
- Absolutely.
Hey, thanks for catching up.
- [Mark] I get that.
If you're not using the
agent, you don't want to call
the agent, and you want to
make it available so that
the keys are right there and somebody
is comfortable with keys can use it.
- He can't do that.
He doesn't have an actual advantage here.
- So why are a million lock boxes,
the traditional lock boxes,
why are a million of them sold a year?
- And why is the other
company have millions
of dollars worth of sales already?
Doing exactly this, all they
have to do is flip one bit
and expand their audience, and they win.
- How do you connect those boxes?
- Good luck guys.
I wish you luck getting your money back.
- [Barbara] Have a seat, Chris.
We all agree we disagree.
(energetic music)
- No you've got it wrong, Chris.
- I sometimes wonder how you
made all that money, Mark.
What's success anyway?
Is success about making the most money?
No, not, no.
Money for the most part,
turns people into jerks.
If you, if you do become rich,
the university fundraising
and development office
will certainly want to stay
in touch with you, and
if you give enough money,
you'll get your name on
a plaque above the dirty
laundry bin here in the men's locker room,
but that still doesn't
make you a great person,
and it definitely doesn't
mean anyone will like you.
I mean, don't get me wrong,
as I mentioned before,
you're never going to feel richer
than when you've paid
off those credit cards
and student loans, but after that,
money tends to be pretty unfulfilling.
Almost all the people I know,
who've made a lot of money,
they've turned into that guy.
All right, well you know
the guy who pops his collar,
and if he, and if it were up
to him, and he were wearing
two shirts, he could pop both collars.
(laughter)
That's the guy.
So how will we know when
we've done it right?
What's the ultimate
measure of success then?
What's the key to success?
Well in my experience, quite simply,
success is happiness.
It all comes down to happiness,
and I definitely don't mean
that happiness that you feel
when the Gophers take over on downs
in their own red zone,
as great as that feels.
I mean that happiness that quite
literally fills your lungs.
The kind of happiness that makes a noise.
It announces its arrival with
a deep inhale and a deep exhale.
(loud breathing)
That happiness.
You know that happiness, right?
That happiness is success because
it turns out happy people get jobs.
Happy people create.
Happy people win.
Happy people fall in
love and raise families.
They lead and change the world.
Happy people get what they want
because often happy people
are the ones who realize
they don't actually need much
more than they already have,
and they appreciate what they've got.
Happy people are contagious.
Some of you aren't founders and you
should admit that to yourselves.
So it's become very
fashionable to start something.
It's amazing you know when
Justin Timberlake plays somebody
in a move about, you know,
about a startup that's awesome.
There are lots of people
making a ton of money
and on magazine covers,
but this is a very special,
different journey that is not
actually suited to everybody.
You have to be a little weird,
a little crazy, a little obsessive.
You probably have some personal issues
that make you different, like you
have some demons a little bit.
You may have trouble relating
to other human beings
from time to time, like you
don't accept failure very well.
Maybe you go off a little
bit, maybe you struggle
a little bit with manic
depression, et cetera.
If none of those things
sound familiar to you,
you should probably quit right now.
(laughter)
And so sorry if that's a
little bit of a downer.
I just, some of you should be employees.
Some of you should be partners.
Some of you should be employee number,
you know number one at a
startup, and I think right now.
Oh that's amazing, they actually
showed us a hurry up please sign.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I know, I divested,
but that's good, but finish with that
because we, that's powerful,
and people should hear that.
- No I, there are founders, and
then there are team members,
and in an era where it's
been so easy to get capital,
I just think the posers should step aside.
I guess I just think our
industry is blind to the impact.
To how,
I think we have written
human beings,
our emotion, our purpose,
our community, our collective humanity,
and our empathy have all been
written out of the algorithm,
and I think that's going
to cost us in the long run.
It will not only help the
rise of despotic leaders,
but I think it's what's actually
severing our connections
between each other.
You know I think
technology has evolved a lot faster
than our primal brains have.
And I think
we've lost track of how
important presence is.
You know, constant
notifications and buzzing
and the impact that's
actually having on our health
and our lives, and so, I
think if we don't wake up
very soon to the absolute dearth
of humanity within what we're
building and have that baked
right into our mission and our values,
our purpose, our hiring, who we brought
into these companies,
then we're going to lose.
We're going to lose not
just on the investor side,
not just on the product side,
but the monoculture will eat itself,
and our entire planet
will suffer as a result.
- Thank you guys, so much for watching.
I made this video because
Rajit Lopa asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next, please
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I 'd also like to know, what
did you learn from Chris
that had the biggest impact on you.
What lesson are you going to apply most
to your businesses or your life?
Please leave it in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally wanted to give a
quick shout-out to Edwin,
who is one of the assistance
at Trinidad Salsa.
Edwin thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, "You One Word."
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and taking that picture
and posting on Facebook.
I'm really feeling the love, man.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.
(percussive music)
- What advice would you give
for someone in their early 20s?
Living in this era, in
this time of the world.
- Everyone spend less money.
I think the freest you'll ever
feel is when you don't owe
anybody any money, when you're,
you have all these choices in the world.
You know, you guys have the benefit of.
I've never went bankrupt.
I've lost tons and tons of money.
Well first of all, in the
United States, we have to pay
a lot of money for school, so that's one
of your competitive advantages.
I left college and then into law school,
so seven years of school, and I owed
like 200 thousand dollars, and that was
twenty years ago, so that's bad.
I think it's already a competitive
advantage you guys have.
And you like get to go to
hospitals and yeah, it's amazing.
All this stuff we're about to break.
- Daycare.
- Did I just start talking
about Donald Trump again?
- Yeah, sorry.
(laughter)
- But so, so I just think one
of the most important things
a young person can do is just
buy less, have less stuff.
Stuff, just, you're a prisoner
to your things, right?
And so you can pick up
and travel more easily.
You can have a smaller house.
You can quit your job
and go work in an NGO,
volunteer work, you can pursue
your art career if you have
less and owe less money to fewer people,
so I think that's like number one.
See now you're not even focused.
- Oh?
- Now you're just trying too hard.
- I'm beginning to think
that maybe you and Matt,
the CEO of Automatic have been playing
on that table a little
bit, and I got suckered.
- I told you earlier, I
like to play rigged games.
I don't invest in companies
where I don't think
we have a competitive advantage
to make it more likely
to win, and I wouldn't have challenged you
to play badminton because I suck.